hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my full playthrough of
the amnesia custom story Gustav alright
so I tried to livestream this but my
computer exploded and I did a graphics
card transplant so now I have instead of
a squirrel running on a treadmill I have
a chipmunk running on a treadmill
so anyway I'm gonna play through the
whole thing because obviously I want you
half of it I don't know how far I went
but I went through a little bit of it
and I feel like I should give you guys
the whole thing so I'm gonna do holder
playthrough if you've already seen some
part skip ahead to where you caught up
to if you haven't seen it all enjoy it
cuz I'm gonna read everything and treat
it like it's just a normal playthrough
okay okay
it is the late spring of 1802 and this
year has thus far been a most
interesting one your talents in
proactive efforts granted you enrollment
in a high quality yet small academy of
alchemic studies nestled deep in Prussia
and your brennenburg the Academy is a
small one taking on no more than eight
pupils run by a single teacher
Alexander Dara the latest a long line of
barons of brennenburg already you have
learned more than you could possibly
hoped and the future is looking very
bright
now stop lately however your roommate
Gustav has been taking lessons with the
bearing and secret of history which
seems to be taking its toll on your
roommates already questionable stability
rumors pass among the other students but
are little more than speculation and
entertainment that is until one night
when you are woken by a most horrible
noise still in the haze from your dreams
you wander the halls to search for
answers possibly fee for your life haha
now if if I don't seem too surprised
when a monster pops out it's cuz I
already know it's gonna pop out that in
there don't be afraid
I don't fake laughs or I don't fake
scares I fake labs all the time but I
don't oh it's a monster
I'm a flu oh no but so don't expect that
I will I thoroughly plan to mess with
the monsters beginning here oh yeah that
doesn't sound too good
I'm just gonna grab most of this is just
the same rooms I'm just gonna grab these
tender boxes and that'd be on my way Oh
Bert no the drink is delicious the drink
is wonderful the drink invigorates me
for I must embark on my quest I drink
these drops in clinton crimson flavor
can run with the birds out there on the
branch while they string up their elixir
in my tribe the Crimson wave crap run
loose Arthur okay the writing becomes
too illegible and smeared and stains
from a tonic so any more tender boxes in
here hi don't fix oh come on aha
wow it was okay still shaking oh I'm so
scared had to noise Oh aha thousand okay
now that I got those tender boxes I can
go on my way I know where to go in the
beginning here
Oh No uh who's there yeah still but it's
okay now go in here I go down here go
over here
aha to their box it'll go here and it's
dark in here
oh yeah that's right key here a bingo
like a mouse yeah I take this key and I
think the door is right over ah oh I I
do remember some of the things that
happen like right here ha ha ha ok
Jerris scuse me need you
oops wait hang on oh yeah the lantern
right here yeah I got that
and where is it ah ha ha ha yeah just
needed to do that no really other reason
[ __ ] crap I forgot I forgot about you
hug uh-huh yeah what's up now yeah
that's right oh yeah keep right here
smile
you didn't hear anything bloody my
friend ha hider gimmick barmy
there we go ah go here and I think
that's it ok we and there's all right
what fire is hey I clicked the door the
drink is wonderful vid rink invigorates
me
I must embark on my quest ok so now
we're done no yeah the lab now first
study private studies first I really
wish that that live stream would have
worked I would I feel like it's more
enjoyable for you all to experience them
the thrill of live skiers for
generations the local countryside has
been rich in folklore in a history of
things most unholy and dark most
famously are tales of encounters with
the gatherers turning once brave men
into timid shells of their former cells
only muttering fragments of disturbing
account from their experience before
breaking into hysteria however on the
20th of June 1793 a small present
village experienced are more than the
trauma and tales an Arnold Richter had
left take work in another village
earlier that week and had not intended
to return for three more days however
late on the night of the 20th the local
constable heard a terrible scream while
on patrol and ran to investigate he
found Arnold on the ground clenching his
stomach with one arm and the other arm
badly disfigured before the constable
could help Arnold to his feet nor
inquire what happened on Hill began
convulsing snapping both his legs and
splitting his abdomen wide his body was
brought into the town morgue shortly
after the next morning the morgue was in
a ruin the walls inside had been clawed
at door was broken down from the inside
out a most disturbing Arnold's body was
missing
unfortunately Arnold had neglected to
mention to his wife where he had gone
for work and so the truth on what
happened to the man is still unknown
hurrah oh I didn't know zis before ha ha
yep Club and another now I write to you
because I wish to attend your Academy of
alchemy kau chemical arts for much of my
life thus far yet I feel I cannot obtain
my true potential on my own I have heard
of your teachings and resources some say
your knowledge is second to none if you
are able to take me on as one as your
pupils I would be greatly in your debt
sincerely Gustav rates the third PS
regardless of my future attendance would
like to have the honor of meeting you
with you in person
where I found a most peculiar etic
remarkably perfect sphere of sorts that
I cannot identify though I believe you
may have the answer the reason I read
all the notes some people asked why
really because I believe I have a good
of voice to give it narration that it's
due and also I never noticed that before
Gustav please make repairs to this door
to fix the jamb replace it if necessary
likewise do not forget to retrieve the
hammer from the sewers when you are done
with it
Alexandre because when I do videos like
this if people don't want me to read it
they can skip through it it's fine I
don't care but I mean some people liked
it when I added a narrative and it gives
a purpose to the story because the
makers of the maps put a lot of effort
into it and I believe that it deserves a
full playthrough
that is required okay um I don't quite
remember click oh yeah I missed the
white box Ramona it's okay it's no big
deal
just my beloved may I finally return you
at long last to my efforts now fail to
bring us together
I rest confident his work shall allow me
to press on Alexander you know it's like
Alexander Alexander has designed a plan
for my preparation for some time now
I'll Jenner has performed rituals on
animals and Leasing powerful elements in
refining a formula for the potent elixir
of life to enhance my own ability we'll
begin these rituals myself have also
resumed work started by a percent
predecessor to increase the production
of the elixirs key ingredients during
rituals his research showed promise but
like himself I was never able to achieve
that ultimate goal I can already see
where he failed and I believe I have a
superior approach with changes to his
work and create a tonic which causes
growth in any being that in vibes it
with this the ingredients production
during rituals should likewise grow I
have no doubt this will provide a boon
of ingredients necessary to advance both
Alexander and myself in our goals
tah-dah I was finally able to present
Alexander the spherical relic I found I
knew I came to the right man when I saw
his eyes light up with the sight of this
orb as he called it according to him
there exist other forms this is mine
it's one possessing great power and an
equally great malice according to
Alexander a few have ever disturbed an
order from its resting place without
paying the ultimate price
I lay up despite its terrible curse I
was able to take this orbit keep it in
my possession for over two years without
consequence Alexander is most impressed
with this ability and tells me that I
may be blessed with the ability to tame
its power a gift also bestowed unto him
already we have begun secret lessons
here hidden beneath the people
dormitories Alexander promises that he
will prepare me for my quest ahead where
Bimal is chief
true greatness together with him using
the orbs power I feel a new chapter of
my life approaching and felt a deep
connection with the orb since I first
encountered it within that African tomb
the angels who have whispered to me
since I was a boy have grown in numbers
and strength since the day I made my
discovery
now they speak to me more than ever
before they foresee my greatness they
inspire my preparation and they warned
me of the jealous anger the other
students must have they know not of this
hidden place but they can sense my
growing power and they burn with envy
one day I will turn their jealousy to
fear and respect cutter also I like
reading haha in case you didn't know
that about me oh yeah I forgot about
that guy ah ha ha with that oh you heard
some oh really come on come on hurry
yeah hey I'll see you there ah oh you
read your ha ha ha ha
gimme pardon me ok it's in here I know
it's in here oh yes this one look for
quick quick lick that box cover oh is
that oh yeah cowabunga
ah no uh-uh a bone a bone a bone flap a
bone a bone
I'm borrowed laughter you creams and
your face and your ugly face ah run run
run on your head close the door and I'll
run faster than ha ha ha get out of here
go go go go go go go yes
I didn't know that another one would
spawn I'm barely conscious uh still
bleeding but whatever ha ha ha I was
awesome uh I thought I was dead for sure
okay now we have officially reached the
part livestream where I did not progress
so I will take it slower and I will
explore everything I also don't like
this part cuz it's a sewer part and a
water part and I don't like the water
parts yep yep I don't like it ah well my
friend and there's nothing under the
stairs don't even ask don't even ask
there's nothing Oh oops huh sploosh
nothing crap yep wish oh hey good thing
there are enough during a recent lesson
I had accidently someone to care can the
sewers below this mistake is shown to be
built a curse and a blessing well I feel
shame for making such a foolish error
any work I carry out here is fraught
with peril
I feel great pride in my ability to make
such an impressive summit it has
provided us with more more thorough
disposal system for spent subjects or
even those who have failed their quest
okay what do you mean by that is Eddie's
bodyguards here lovely okay I'm gonna
take this nice juicy tours oh and uh
throw it over there all right you go
Keuka ho you go up off for the rest of
your life oh and I crashed right here
before in case you're curious sorry
ah not another one okay don't collapse
go fall like a but also skill oh crap Oh
Megan Megan Megan yeah I totally knew I
could do that the whole time another one
hey bear hey lack boughs today bones huh
well it's not gonna get it there all
right okay that one's happy over there
there are times I do not understand
Alexander not an hour ago he was
praising me on my powers telling me how
I am different from the others in my
predecessors now it is my responsibility
to come down here and fix this machine
and mince the carrots who follow my
every step their savage beasts and
should not exist in any realm still find
comfort in the whispers of angels at
times like these they reassure me of my
greatness and give me the determination
to endure such hardships ha ha ha
their voices continue to grow louder so
they are coming closer to watch me
finally begin my quest I have it I'm
nearly ready ha ha ha hello-o
oh I'm not good oh don't tell me I don't
wanna I don't wanna wait there was a
hand I saw it
can't fool me oh this is not good you're
gonna make me run back aren't you
I'll let it die I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die Oh gimme barmy
ah come on jump on the goop up but yeah
okay hey look it's a body part go get it
oh god I got a hammer oh my god
Oh spiral staircase that's right huh ah
good good
Oh got all over my face yeah can't stop
me I'm so bad at out out can't stop me
I'm like the best there ever was and
everything
gimme chair okay nevermind good I find
comfort in the whispers of angels at
times like these it refer me reassure me
of my greatness
okay that's Oh Brody
oh that's something good thing they gave
me this
ah if you cuz I'm bruised is still kind
of insane though so um
i'ma gonna hammer this door don't know
like a both duh don't know what that did
exactly
ah bye oh boy alright buddy where you
going oh um this baby
oh they only tortured me for five days
Oh suck it up be brave like me the hell
is this hello
turn the box Wow oh ma hey what the hell
Oh No Hey do not throw a gigantic
crunket at a grunt at me ha ha ha it
appears the growth formula actually
contains two active ingredients one for
growth and one for incredible strength
and subsequent violence we've observed
fine tuning my materials and methods
have altered the proportion of these two
parts of the formula the effects seem to
vary but a high dose of a strength agent
seems to allow the subject to survive
the disfiguring caused by the growth
agent however they seem to now respond
to feelings of pain or suffering even
when we managed to restrain them for a
ritual making them useless I must find a
way to protect this
go big naked get some freaky music oh no
where to be uh okay I might be in
trouble here come through the door you
want your chair up your butt
I'm just warning you man I've been
taking strength potion I can shove this
up your Oh Oh with that huh
you're on is it go it's gonna be like
that hey I'm gonna be like that can't
see me
I got a chair in front my face isn't
working is it
he's not gonna work hahaha did he go
away oh yeah oh whoa oh no uh-huh yeah
run away I'm a boss oh you hear anything
buddy I didn't hit anything
ha ha ha can ya do it
good good oh I'm good to go get on on
slow I'm gonna die oh my god I'm gonna
die
let me let man I mean I get it oh damn
it take me all right okay
okay all right I I asked for that one oh
no what do you do all right take two oh
man oh oh
all right I've never seen it whoa hello
loading I don't know what that was
tender box give it
grab it I don't care if it's in the
bones give it just coz some dirty you
think I'm not gonna use it you thought
wrong I've used many a dirty thing
before I know that's not a useful
euphemism but hot damn look at this guy
oh I thought that was glass ah ha my
mistake I seriously thought that was
glass oh well this is lovely
I like this damn look at this guy
ha ha ha we got it oh I guess I could
have hidden here maybe I don't know
empty good
alright breathe is nota but this is good
subject has grown by considerable
amounts but unfortunately the same
disfiguration an eventual organ rupture
eventually curses with non-human test
subjects even worse death occurs before
our rituals can begin making their
growth useless for our purposes the
blood does not seem to produce any
higher concentrations the ingredients we
need I can only hope that the right
combination of the growth agent and
strength agent can yield us specimens
who can survive long enough for the
rituals to begin it still be affected by
them right I mean wow oh yeah okay now
is there anything in here this is uh huh
let's get out of here
carrying on moving forward oh damn man
fire hello oh my god damn it there's a
monster out there the subject has grown
to enormous proportions and was imbued
with immense strength and violent
behavior shortly after being fed the
latest formula
unfortunately the subject seems to be
completely impervious to pain during
rituals producing a little of the
desired ingredients I'm beginning to
grow desperate to find a solution to
this problem I feel that I'm so close my
quest is almost at hand I cannot let
this fail alright Gustav oh hello
hahaha oh come on holy hell Agrippa you
grew up
ah crap oh crap
you didn't see anything you saw nothing
oh good look over oh is he going away
you know usually do that they don't
usually just bust out a door and not
come back or not come inside okay man
mmm
man how are you
you look well except for the whole being
gigantic thing probably bad but uh carry
on
ah come on no no no no aha you got ya
wonk
I just what's on okay another one you
want a second dose of Blanc how about I
thought I need a lot
I need a lever I'm gonna wreck it imma
die I'm gonna die again let's fail
barrel back
you got swamped Oh Lee Kuber skills on
so cloned you can't find me I'm here oh
crap
this is a bad choice this is a bad
choice up there goes hi buddy ah gosh
ha ha ha ha ah
also bad choice Oh epic I'm like a boss
yo what's that oh crap gasping what's in
the Oh dead body I've got bigger boot
down no okay box it is like awesome I'm
like the best ever
Oh
oh no no no hear about it I thought the
door would open oh okay all right
tah-dah back to
of me
not of that wait I'm back here up poop
all right moving on
there's mr. big man mr. bigger man is
over here everybody okay
moving forward yeah uh no I don't think
so
not even in oh no not not at all okay so
that guy's dead nothing in there how
much oil I got plenty plenty of oil it's
in here nothing
wonder if they built like that chamber
for the big guy I mean of course video
game oh come on guy another one I guess
I'll hide this one out and not be stupid
like I had before hey buddy how about
you'd go away huh how about that that'd
be nice don't let down my door please
alright buddy you want to go toe-to-toe
with me you didn't like that last time
don't come around this corner
haha no no that's right that's right hey
get out of here oh what's wrong can't
find me
oh maybe could you show stupid dude I'm
so smart but I'm a big smarty he's a big
dummy huh huh huh huh you like money and
- - we should befriend his intentions
are followed and greed his mind slips
through the cracks his work may fail me
but the true gift is only in my hands
now it will be with you soon my love
fella that's obviously a cloud all right
so like sense now
the failure was only a sign from the
spirits it was never my destiny to help
Alexander I was meant to find the key to
my own greatness the growth and strength
agents I created on my true destiny
the spirits finally speak their message
to me
they command me to drink my own creation
and become a being of unstoppable power
and greatness all will know their
inferiority as the blood spills to the
earth okay Gustav has crazy and maybe
you'll have to fight it like a gigantic
Gustav that
nothing else here Oh doc complainin I
was down here this is where I died
where my blood spilled
okay I hear a monster that's supposed to
be a phonograph guessing these are just
torture us rody okay but is there any
reason besides that dude oh come on oh
now I'm all insane and stuff all right I
got a glass jar don't oh it's filled
with oil okay I don't know why but it is
why is that wet way that it is Oh
perhaps some oil will loosen your lips I
bet I get oh come on oh come on
I'm sad now see my sad face field guard
for me I almost had it
okay carrying on come on what am I
supposed to do you say give me the
there's a monster behind me noise and
you don't expect me to try to wheel the
thing up this is two anyway
I need to find a lever for this or
something Oh No look I don't know I
don't know what that's all about
oh come on oh wait no that monsters
still there right oh yeah
that monster never despawned past it
there was an odorous about to close by
me right what is this wheel
no it's not you and I er there we go ah
locking mechanism disengaged forward am
I about to face Gustav and I about to
see the monster that he has become looks
like
maybe not yet
now interesting uh-uh no uh-uh not
having it get it out of here get out of
here okay
hello Alex Josh Wow
it shall not be much longer now ceremony
is nearly ready
soon I will return to the place where I
belong must be the final trace of my
presence in this realm Alexander so
egotistical he has a giant painting of
himself behind him at all times
is that it nothing else maybe this is
more of a final place I don't see
anything I'm looking I'm looking
don't see nothing okay nothing carry on
oh wait no what's uh no what uh he'll
they'll be peas wet no you ought know
okay up the stairs nice purple glow
though like that effect don't no way
it's awfully brightly lit up here it's
almost cheerful and nice oh ah I just
had to say something
okay ah dork Oh
that's good whatever that was I'm sure
it was phenomenal now the holy speaker
don't
what is that sound
like some rumbling in that I don't know
I'm guessing I go down here ah I hate
these tunnels ahead
ever since lost the light ahead don't
don't
heroine rushing from the don't super be
ready
be enough time
oh hey what the
ha da hell
close I thank you
haha what I'm guessing that was Gustav
Alexander not happy
haha your life flashes before your eyes
is a rock soil and debris and tune your
helpless body just an instant the whole
lifetime of experiences moved through
your consciousness each memory taking
one last stand in that spot light before
it blinks out of existence for eternity
who stuff was not so fortunate to share
similar experience his body disfigured
and mind in tatters he was hardly aware
of his actions when his life was
instantly cut short such a rush of
memory sadly would not be part of his
final moment the immense skull pressure
begins to reach the limit of your skulls
durability for an instant your mind
thinks of your family and loved ones
before you slip into the eternal
Hereafter
special thanks to mr. big Z for the
ragdoll ground model you got it mister
Thank You mr. big Z I'm not speaking I
was about to say you're welcome
That's not me either way that was cool
that was cool I really like that custom
story I mean just the gigantic things
everywhere very very entertaining
altogether I'm glad that I was able to
play the whole thing at once and I know
I was about halfway through it when I
got to the point where it crash so I
hope you all enjoy this look forward to
next week's live stream where I will
have all this sorted out and I will be
able to play the entire game during live
stream for your entertainment and
hopefully I'll get about three done one
long one two short ones three short ones
one really I don't know three we're
aiming for three so hopefully you'll be
able to join me next Sunday at 5 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time they start a
little early I'm gonna shoot for 5
though so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye